when i came to the table on dates and i
said to myself it wasn't like i'm going
to go in and i'm not going to sleep with
this person for x amount it's not that
it's a matter of comfort it's a matter
of genuinely feeling like someone is
there for the right reasons
that's where we're going to differ
because sex is not about comfort it's
about discomfort it's about urgency it's
about it's about i got to get with this
guy i'm i will break my rules to get
with this guy because he's so hot and
i'm so into this dude that i want to
give you're not comfortable
when when a man is having sex with you
if you're uncomfortable
you're going to be uncomfortable and i
mean uncomfortable and sense of urgency
urgency sure but you can what i'm saying
is don't judge book by cover in the
sense of you don't know what i've got
going on inside i may be dying asleep
with you i may be sitting across i'm
married now so i'm talking about my old
self i may be on a date and be like oh
man this guy has he's so hot i may call
my friend after the show and be like oh
my god he's so hot you know what i'm
saying whatever i'm doing at the time